deuce
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis well
as kinderzimmer video habt ihr ja schon
gesehen und alle haben direkt nach
samira ist immer gefragt also zeige ich
euch heute so miraß kinderzimmer in
diesem video erfährst du worauf es bei
der möbel auswahl eines grundschulkindes
ankommt mit welchen techniken ich die
wände streichen wie du ein do it
yourself leucht bild gestalten und wie
du den buchstaben für die wanddekoration
herstellen kannst sanierer ist ja
mittlerweile schon acht jahre alt also
wirklich unglaubliche acht jahre alt die
zeit vergehen einfach viel zu schnell
und als mama einer achtjährigen muss man
sich natürlich überlegen ok momentan ist
noch ein kind aber in zwei bis drei
jahren ist er schon und teenager das
heißt zu kindlich darf das kinderzimmer
dann gar nicht eingerichtet werden denn
sie möchte er mit dem kinderzimmer
mitwachsen es darf also nicht so
kindisch sein das darf nicht uncool sein
und es darf finde ich auch nicht zu bunt
sein für samira habe ich mir deswegen
zwei farbe ausgesucht einmal so ein
dunkleres petrol einmal ein rosé und ich
denke das passt auch ganz gut zu ihrem
alter
bevor ihr euch die möbel aussucht
solltet ihr erst einmal überlegen was
braucht das kind überhaupt sanierer ist
wie gesagt acht jahre alt geht schon die
zweite klasse und braucht natürlich
einen richtig guten und komfortablen
schreibtisch an dem sie dann
hausaufgaben machen kann an denen sie
aber auch arbeiten und spielen und malen
kann zum schlafen hat sich samira ein
hochbett gewünscht da muss ich sagen
haben wir ganz heiß diskutiert ich bin
nämlich absolut ein hochbett regner
sanieren möchte aber unbedingt eins also
werden wir nach einem hochbett schauen
mit gäste übernachtungsmöglichkeit für
ihre freundinnen für ihre kleidung
benötigt sie einen großen kleiderschrank
dann bekommt sie eventuell einen friseur
bzw schminktisch und für ihre
bastelsachen und ihre wenigen
spielsachen die sie hat braucht es
natürlich auch noch stauraum
bei den möbeln haben uns wirklich sehr
viel zeit gelassen bei der auswahl und
wir haben uns dann dazu entschlossen ein
möbelhaus auszuwählen damit wir einfach
bei der lieferung wirklich nur einen lkw
haben und so wenig teillieferungen wie
möglich haben wir haben uns online
umgeschaut und auch im online shop von
xxx lutz und haben uns dann dafür
entschieden weil wir gedacht haben dort
gibt es einfach eine große vielfalt dort
gibt es viele verschiedene marken und
man hat wirklich was in allen preislagen
und dann haben wir uns trotzdem gegen
einen online kauf entschieden denn ich
finde möbel gerade badmöbel
schlafzimmermöbel schreibtische die muss
man sich einfach live vor ort anschauen
auch mal ausprobieren draufsitzen die
höhe verstellen können und dann kann man
entscheiden passt das weg zu mir oder zu
meinem kind und ich nehme euch jetzt mal
mit zum xxx nach karlsruhe
beim xxx lutz haben wir uns dann dort
umgeschaut und man hat dort natürlich
auch immer eine fachberatung das heißt
wenn einem dann ein möbelstück gefällt
kann man sich den fachberater zur seite
ziehen ausfragen man kann auch fragen
wie hat die möbel stammen und der kennt
sich da meist immer bestens aus ich
finde das hier ist schon so einen jugend
und erwachsenen zimmer also dann schon
mit einem großen bett und hier platz für
fernsehen zum beispiel und meine kids
sie bekommen keinen fernseher in ihr
zimmer
dafür ist definitiv zu führen wir haben
auch keinen fernseher bei uns im
schlafzimmer also nur bei uns im boden
zimmer dafür nicht okay und hier ist
eben auch schon platz für einen großen
schrank aber dafür ist die echt noch
zwischen zu ab 16 und 17 finde ich so
ein zimmer dann echt gut ich weiß ein
liebes schönes haus auf grüner hügel
halte das hlug den zweite land hinaus
und ist begrenzt vom walde und vor ihm
weithin sichtbares sicht wahrlich was
ist das denn wollen ein hoher mast bau
steht in seinem hof ein nussbaum wächst
mit weit verzweigten essen ein
springbrunnen plätschert erhard und
wachet nacht für nacht verschmäht des
schlafes lage sei ruhig herz auch die
einmal ist todes ruhe beschieden
[Musik]
zweites gesicht ein törtchen törtchen
schwarzwälder kirsch so rolf stückrath
auch ich gucke nur die sachen das ist
nicht unser kinderzimmer
du musst dich auch schon farbe des
holzes riecht so gut er merkt man
einfach echte folgerichtig haben würfel
hat es ja auch kohle raus jetzt auch ein
buch vertreten gekümmert
ich find's cool bei mir hat es ja
anfangs ein hochbett gewünscht wobei ich
immer am anfang der gegenwart ja wenn
man sich das heraus fällt aber ich
glaube mittlerweile ist er alt genug und
damals auch den dänischen hersteller
hier ausgesucht wird auch wieder dieses
schöne abgerundeten kanten sag ich jetzt
mal und gerade so kleine details wie
hier die lasche das eben beim
hochsteigen oder beim runtergehen auch
sich festhalten kann
also ich find's cool praktisch um die
ecke so ein kleines sofa und kann
tagsüber darauf lesen oder einfach mal
ein bisschen kuscheln mit ihrer
schwester und nachts wenn sie doch mal
besucht hat mädels besucher wird ein
ganzes ausziehen sondern gäste wird in
der show für die stabile ja doch jetzt
finde ich gut
samira ist schon ein bisschen älter das
heißt wer würde ich jetzt per teilnehmen
und rosé weil sie die farben zum einen
sehr gern mag und ich finde es muss
einfach so ein zurückhaltendes rosa und
die zwei passen ganz gut und ich denke
an den farben sieht sie sich dann auch
nichts dass die wandfarbe mache ich dann
auch dementsprechend und dann passt das
glaube ich echt guten mehr zimmer
[Musik]
buch
es war ein schöner schreibtisch aber ich
glaube zu statisch gesehen aber so eine
kommode ist auch ganz cool
doch mal immer um alles zu verstehen was
man am schreibtisch braucht bei kindern
weniger auf auf der steil gehen oder
stylisch wichtig die kinder klar
das ist sehr schön funktional sitzt ja
auch nach der schule am schreibt gemacht
wer will daheim ein bisschen design aber
auch bequemlichkeit auf die
tatsächlichen organisation und passt
sogar der spitze reinigte den spitz hat
jeder oder ja ich hoffe ihr geredet der
produktplatzierung machen zu wollen
faber castell barriere cool da kann sie
hier ihren schreibblock oder malblock
stifter finde ich auch schön das ist
schön
also am schreibtisch achten wir bei
samira auf jeden fall darauf dass er
einen guten schreibtisch hat den mann in
der höhe verstellen kann dem auch hier
so kippen kann der stuhl muss wirklich
super sein sofa gemütlich der muss
mitwachsen können weil sie ist jetzt in
der zweiten klasse und ich meine das
zimmer hat sie jetzt über die nächsten
jahre
und wenn der tisch und stuhl nicht
mitwachsen dann muss schon wieder in
zwei jahren was neues kaufen weil jetzt
wächst sehr schnell
daher ist es jetzt eine gute investition
ich bin auch mega schnell gewachsen wo
ich sagen ja ich wollte mir so schnell
gewachsen dass ich mit 14 schon fertig
war nicht wachsen und mit 12
minute die möbel bestellt habt dann
könnt ihr die zwischenzeit nutzen um das
zimmer zu streichen
ich nehme einfach aus dem möbelhaus ein
paar farbmuster mit kann dementsprechend
die farben aussuchen und das zimmer und
die wände gestalten die kinderzimmer
waren alle schon vor tapeziert alles mit
glasfaser tapeten und die sind bereits
vor gefärbt das heißt alle schon weiß
gestrichen
ich habe mir jetzt für die kinderzimmer
bunte farben ausgesucht und bunte wände
damit sie einfach nicht so langweilig
sind und damit der stoff besser zur
geltung kommt was ich oben einen weißen
streifen
dafür zeichne ich einfach eine linie mit
einem bleistift vor mit der wasserwaage
alles schön im wasser und dann wird es
gar
abgeklebt
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier wieder gold band und
damit klebe ich den streifen jetzt ab
und zwar ein millimeter ungefähr über
dem bleistift später bleistiftstrich
einfach nicht mehr zu sehen ist
und da ist immer wichtig dass es schön
gerade wird keine kleinen stücke sondern
wir die schön am stück lassen und eine
gerade durchziehen
das brauche ich auch so eine leiter wie
demand die hier laufen mit ihrer leider
aber das muss ich noch üben komplett
die restliche summe soll dann blut
[Musik]
fertig muss echt sagen es geht einfacher
wenn man richtig gutes gold band artig
hat normalerweise immer als aus dem
baumarkt das war immer nicht so ganz gut
klebt nicht gut aber das hier schmeckt
einfach mag das ist super und jetzt habe
ich hier den streifen abgeklebt und dann
dicht ich jetzt hier das ganze mit der
weißen farbe ab die ich hier oben und
für die decke auch schon benutzt habe
und auf der wand und dann bekomme ich
den perfekten geraden strich und hier
ist einfach nur wichtig nehme wenig
farbe auf den pinsel streift es auch
schön ab und dann streich von unten nach
oben gegen das bank damit ist einfach
schön abgedichtet wird und die dunklere
farbe nicht durchläuft
[Musik]
ich habe immer mal wieder so gucken und
wenn man dann einen dunklen fleck sie
dann sieht man auch dass da noch eine
vertiefung ist und dadurch stand noch
mehr farbe darüber kann somit in ein
tierheim bringen
ja du bist doch ein starkes mädchen nur
starke frauen hier aber monat
[Musik]
der weiße anstriche sitzt fertig so
sollen wir das zimmer später aussehen
die beiden wände also fenster und hier
links mache ich rosé und die beiden
patrone
los gehts jetzt also mit der farbe oben
das war es trocknet jetzt gerade aber
ich kann da unten schon anfangen
jetzt geht's an die farbe und ich nehme
jetzt hier eine kleine walze und werde
jetzt erstmal oben den rand machen und
haben wir schon teilweise gemacht und
dann einfach mit der großen rolle einmal
komplett drüber bei der farbe ist ganz
wichtig die haben jetzt auch im baumarkt
anmischen lassen
früher habe das immer gerne gemacht
haben einfach weiße farbe genommen dann
so ein bisschen dispersionsfarbe und
reingeschüttet das ist dann so wie
kuchenbacken ohne rezept improvisiertes
rezept und wenn man dann aber später
noch mal die gleiche farbe braucht trägt
man sie nie mehr wieder so hin
das heißt wenn ihr euer zimmer streich
last wirklichen baumarkt anmischen da
gibt es die rezeptur dazu und später
könnte einfach mit der fahrt immer noch
mal hingehen nochmal einmal dazu
bestellen
wir hatten jetzt nämlich auch einfach
fünf liter einmal gemerkt ok doppelte
anstrich reicht nicht aus also will man
noch mal fünf liter und so kann man es
einfach ein bisschen besser machen und
jetzt hier oben einfach nur aufpassen
dass man natürlich nicht über das
klebeband kommt sondern nur bis zum
klebeband machen
zudem sind vorsichtige arbeit und später
geht es wieder ein bisschen schneller
[Musik]
hierüber der tür mache ich jetzt auch
noch das stück damit man da nicht mit
der großen rolle drauf muss und hier
muss ich jetzt einfach nur aufpassen
dass ich nicht so fest drückt damit die
farbe hin die tür rein läuft wenn wir
hier so ganz bündige türen ohne anderen
ohne rahmen deswegen bleibt es so
[Musik]
jetzt bessern wir hier informieren wir
die leisten aus da haben nämlich auch
das problem dass ein bisschen silikon
oder aufkleber von den leisten da ist
und deswegen die farbe einfach nicht
hält jetzt haben wir hier schon richtig
schön abgeklebt und da kommt jetzt ein
bisschen acryl darüber aktuell kann man
ja toll überstreichen und dann gehen wir
einfach noch mal mit der zimmer farbe
drüber und dann haben wir den perfekten
abschluss habe ich ihr das acryl fugen
dicht in einer pistole dass es vorne
hier angesteckt und jetzt setz dir das
hier einfach an mit leichter mit ruhm
[Musik]
hier in gänze und dann einfach das
überschüssige material mit dem finger
weg nehmen
[Musik]
da könnt ihr direkt in wien zu nehmen
die wandfarbe ganz vorsichtig und ohne
druck darüber streichen damit sich das
acryl nicht wieder farbe für mich
natürlich über acryl ist man ganz
wichtig das klebeband gleich weggezogen
wird bevor es aber wird das mache ich
sofort sobald ich die komplette wand
fertig haben
[Musik]
guckt mal jetzt haben einen perfekten
abschluss
da kann natürlich nur so perfekt werden
wie abgeklebt habt jetzt ist es endlich
soweit das zimmer ist fertig gestrichen
der liefertermin wurde vereinbart und
jetzt kommt der möbel aufbau service
durch möbel aufbauen
[Musik]
jetzt sind die möbel für samira ist
immer da und die jungs waren schon ganz
fleißig auf natürlich das wichtigste
erst mal bei mir rassistisch im herbst
sicher gewünscht
es wird ja nicht so ein schminktisch
diesen monat so alt aber da kann es die
haare kämmen drauf machen
und jetzt steht hier erstmal alles drin
und ich muss sagen ich bin ganz froh
dass wir die möbel diesmal nicht selber
aufbauen sondern dass wir den service
nutzen weil weiß auch mit paketen
ich glaube 68 pakete sind gelb 68 pakete
ich meine da muss man sich erst mal
überblick verschaffen und die profis
hier brauchen wahrscheinlich schon den
ganzen tag und ich glaube wir als möbel
aufbau leihen würden dann wahrscheinlich
5 tage brauchen oder länger und man
komme ich gleich dazu und habe ja auf
dem ipad mir schon gezeichnet und
ausgezeichnet welche möbelstücke wohin
kommen und dann gucken wir gleich
übersehen stellen aber erstmal muss
aufgebaut werden
[Musik]
was ist bei geschwisterkindern übrigens
ganz praktisch finde wir haben uns die
gleiche möbelserie ausgesucht für samira
und für ella das war so eine dänische
firma und da ist ganz praktisch wenn man
das gleiche hat denn die kleine die
wächst hier raus die große wächst raus
und dann können wir zum beispiel später
einfach so miraß bett zu erstellen
samira bekommt man was größeres und er
kann einfach die gebrauchten möbel ihrer
schwester nehmen das ist super weil man
es einfach untereinander kombinieren
kann und die möbel passen einfach immer
perfekt zueinander
[Musik]
jetzt gucken rathenow die kleineren
regale machen
ich finde die eigentlich immer ganz
praktisch so für die wand
jetzt hier sieht alles irgendwie ein
bisschen anders aus aber jetzt machen
wir die zwei regale auf jeden fall mal
da oben hin dass an ihrer jetzigen
hochbett und dann kann sie sich dadurch
einen tempos reinlegen und alles was er
nachts braucht muss man hier dass man
vom kampf unter kappeln und ursprünglich
war gedacht ich nämlich schmale regale
und machte direkt übers bett aber ich
habe angst dass der dann nachts aufwacht
und sich den kopf an doch am stück
deswegen machen wir dich hier hin
[Musik]
das eigentlich nur zwei kleiderschränke
geplant jetzt haben irgendwie drei ich
glaube außerdem sind drei verstand aber
ist auch okay weil dann hat alles platz
hier drin
[Musik]
als ihr bett musste mir da oben alleine
machen jeden tag
das mache ich nicht man kann räume immer
ziemlich schön wohnlich gestalten wenn
man einfach so ein bisschen kunstfell
nimmt was eben in der passenden farbe
immer erhältlich ist und dann einfach
irgendwo darüber legen und dann finde
ich sie immer schon richtig schön warm
aus und gemütlich einfach zum
reinkuscheln traumfänger denn eigentlich
zum bett
[Musik]
so war es erstmal
und jetzt kann ich zu hause die alten
sachen ausräumen und hier das zimmer
ausstatten
[Musik]
wir wohnen jetzt schon seit etwa vier
monaten hier im haus unserer meere hat
am anfang oben geschlafen bis es dann
passiert ist sie ist aus dem bett
gefallen und die samira ich habe mir
noch gedacht aber ein hochwertiges
jedoch nicht so gut geeignet denn samira
schläft sei wild und die dreht sich dann
im bett und dann landet am ende hier
mein kopf und ich hier einfach die
treppe runter gerutscht
das war uns jetzt so gefährlich außerdem
versucht ella ständig aufs bett zu
klettern ist mir auch so gefährlich weil
es einfach ein sehr hohes bett ist und
wenn die da kopfüber runterfällt nicht
mehr ganz aus mal was da passiert also
haben wir uns gedacht wir schrauben das
bett wieder herunter und zum glück ist
es ja auch so ein flexibles bett das
heißt man kann ja das bett wenn man
steve gekauft hat auch erhöhen oder wenn
wir uns hoch gekauft hat auch tiefer
legen und so machen wir das jetzt wir
machen das so ich habe hier diese
matratze und dieses sofa für gäste das
heißt wir sagen was freunde und ich habe
mir jetzt gedacht wir nehmen einfach nur
den mittelteil raus was ich von hier ist
hier und können praktisch das bett
runtersetzen und ich denke dass dann
noch das gästebett darunter passt wir
probieren es aus
[Musik]
und ursprünglich war ja meine idee dass
ich hier so eine schöne kuschelecke
macht ich hätte dann hier innen ich habe
sogar schon gekauft neckar dienen stange
aufgehängt und dann einfach so ein
schlafender schlafen gardine dran
man hätte das einfach so zu ziehen
können wenn sie zum beispiel in ruhe was
lesen will oder mit ihrer schwester
kuscheln will aber ja das fällt jetzt
weg
[Musik]
ich kümmere mich um die einrichtung
jetzt kommt die wandgestaltung sanierer
ist acht jahre alt das heißt kein
kleinkind mehr und es darf schon was
besonderes sein
hier an die petrol farbene wand kommt
jetzt ein großer buchstabe nämlich ein
sb sanierer und das ganze wird mit
blumen beklebt da mach ich jetzt
die gestaltung also das ausschneiden
alleine und später nach zwei metern beim
bekleben helfen jetzt schneide ich
zuerst einmal eine schablone zu
dafür nehme ich ein großes blatt papier
ich habe jetzt einfach in den alten
kalender aus dem letzten jahr genommen
auf die rückseite vorgezeichnet und kann
so die schablone nehmen und später auf
holz übertragen
die schablone klebe ich jetzt hier auf
eine sperrholzplatte die s 8 mm stark
das habe ich einfach eine schöne
stabilität und krebs jetzt einfach kurz
an dann mit diesen seiten kann
[Musik]
auf dem holz hier kann ich es jetzt auch
noch mal ausbessern falls mit der stadt
doch nicht so gut gefällt
ich stelle jetzt noch auf und schon
etwas weiter weg drauf dann sieht man
auch ob der buchstabe an der einen
stelle zu klein oder zu dick zu dünn
und dann kann ich das ganze mit einer
stichsäge auslegen
[Musik]
zum schleifen nämlich jetzt ein ex
endlosschleife schleife geht aber
natürlich auch die männer haben ja die
werkstatt zur gut ausgestattet da
bediene ich mich natürlich am werkzeug
[Musik]
1 buchstabe ist 65 auf 35 groß und jetzt
mache ich den rahmen und las hier
einfach wie viele puffer zehn zentimeter
auf jeder seite das heißt mein stück
rahmen wird insgesamt machen wir 56 55
auf etwa 80 bis 85
ja so groß wie der schockraum ich habe
jetzt meine stück leisten die hatte ich
noch übrig von der decke und die muss
jetzt im prinzip zu schneiden die müsste
halt im winkel zum schneiden 45 grad
also auf gehrung damit einfach ein
schöner rahmen entsteht
ich habe jetzt hier das erste stück zwar
noch im rest steuere ich jetzt zu und
dann entsteht gleich der rahmen
[Musik]
perfekt oder super so jetzt alle vier
teile und dann kann ich schon zusammen
kleben
[Musik]
und da könnt ihr einfach die zwei
gegenüberliegenden seiten zusammen legen
und schauen hier exakt aufeinander
ob sie gleich lang sind ich nehme das
sprühfarbe
ihr könnt auch gerne mit dem pinsel
streichen aber dann hab da eventuell
pinselstriche drauf wir müssen darauf
achten dass die farbe eben auch für den
stuttgart ist und natürlich outdoor das
ist eine farbe die ich in door benutzen
kann aber sprühend durch trotzdem gerne
draußen wegen den garten
[Musik]
was für ein schöner nebeneffekt die
steine sind schön schadet das der
terrasse drauf kommt
[Musik]
und trocknen lassen sehr sehr schön hier
auf dieses feld kommt der buchstabe mit
den blumen und der bilderrahmen
jetzt kann ich hier außenrum noch ein
paar goldene punkte machen die mache ich
jetzt mit acrylfarbe und verwendet dafür
einen schwamm
entweder nimmt dir so einen runden
schwamm oder neben anderen schwamm und
schneidet ihnen einfach rum zu
[Musik]
und dann einfach ein bisschen in die
farbe tore und dann an die wand
[Musik]
mittlerweile habe ich den buchstaben
jetzt schon teilweise beklebt sie weiß
natürlich noch nicht was daraus entsteht
aber sie weiß schon ist mit was blumiges
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier ganz viele
kunstblumen einfach gekauft habe hier
unten den stil entfernt und von den
farben her bin ich hier relativ ähnlich
also wo see und blautöne helle töne und
einfach so ein bisschen grün mit rein
das sieht echt schön aus einfach alle
stiele entfernen und weil so großen
blumen
die kann man auch endete abzupfen oder
eben auch abschneiden
und dann legt man sie erst mal hier grob
hin
ich habe jetzt hier unten und auch hier
irgend jeweils 1x und das dann später
einfach das bohrloch da weiß ich hier
keine blume draufkleben sondern einfach
noch mal lücken lassen
beim aufkleben einfach erst mal die
blumen hinlegen so mit den kleinen fühle
ich immer schön die lücken aus oder
später einfach nichts mehr von holz zu
sehen ist und es klappt am besten und
heißkleber weil er zum einen so ein
bisschen 3d er klebt und zum anderen
einfach relativ schnell fest wird
[Musik]
für dich selbst zufrieden hier oben habe
ich die lücke das klebe ich da noch an
hier unten habe ich die lücke jetzt
können wir in so miraß thema gehen
geboren und dann noch die letzten sieg
das holz werde jetzt hier frau gebaut
dann hab ich gleich ein bisschen
einfacher und kann vor allem durch die
bauliche hindurch dass es dann an die
wand halten und dann die bohrlöcher eben
schon anmalen
die punkte selbst auch endlich
getrocknet ok ich es hier hinhalten und
starten die löcher kennzeichnen wo ist
es denn hier meine zwei punkte und da
kann ich jetzt bohren die dübel rein
schlagen und dann das ganze fest
und alles gleich wieder sauber
jetzt noch die restlichen blumen an
leben das mache ich jetzt hier direkt
und danach kann ich den stock rahmen der
jetzt bereits getrocknet ist auch
erklärt wie das schön
es muss nur noch den rahmen festkleben
da habe ich den innenmaß von der länge
her von 85 dann messe ich ganz kurz noch
mal meine blumen zu einer etwas 70
eigentlich sind zehn zentimeter oben
unten aber die blumen stehen ja ein
bisschen über von daher hab ich das
jetzt als puffer mitgerechnet jetzt von
hier praktisch 7 anhalt also hier muss
der rahmen innenkante sitzen
[Musik]
so wie ich jetzt hier einfach die mitte
mit einem klebeband damit ich nicht auf
den rahmen muss das heißt der untere
rahmen hier muss hier kennen und dann
muss ich es nur noch nach dem wasser
ausrichten und antreten
[Musik]
das erste setzt hier klebestreifen
brauche ich nicht mehr
jetzt halte ich es einfach zur kontrolle
mal dran
jetzt habe ich noch ein paar blumen
übrig und die klebe jetzt hier an den
rahmen von samira schminktisch
[Musik]
zuerst war es nun einfacher schminktisch
und jetzt ist es ein richtig schöner
versöhnlicher schminktisch gefällt mir
sehr gut
[Musik]
ich lebe hier eine leinwand für die
ballerina und habe mir einfach online
nieselwetter ausgesucht die habe ich
jetzt ausgedruckt und die denn auch so
cool ich gleich jetzt weiß ich ungefähr
dass die ballerina so groß sein wird
das heißt der rock ist etwa in der mitte
das mache ich ein bisschen größer denn
da kommen ja die pompons bei mir darauf
diese toppings und ich kann jetzt zuerst
einmal dem hintergrund gestalten und
dafür nehme ich mir einfach verschiedene
farben
ich habe ich acrylfarben und auch noch
dass die raum farbe von samaras wand und
gebe jetzt einfach die farbe direkt auf
die leinwand und verstreicht sie einfach
und da gucke ich nur was daraus entsteht
oben mach ich so etwas heller und unten
etwas dunkler damit ich einfach ein
kontrast habt zum hellen kleid
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht so lasse könnte ich es
als teure kunst verkaufen
so machen es die künstler ballerinas
sind ja und jetzt nehme ich einfach
meine winkel palette aus der küche
einmal rund ein mal spitz unterteil die
farben und dann habe ich hier noch mal
eine tankkarte ich glaube damit kann ich
auch so ein bisschen was ziehen und so
gestaltet jetzt dahinter kommen
[Musik]
das nämlich noch ein bisschen weiß man
macht es einfach von innen aus ein
bisschen heller
und jetzt mache ich noch ein bisschen
weicher die übergänge zumindest an ein
paar stellen und dann muss ich das bild
jetzt erstmal trocknen lassen damit ich
gleich die silhouette drauf zeichnen
kann
das ist mein bild der hintergrund ich
weiß nicht so genau wie ich es nennen
soll
wenn ich jetzt ein berühmter künstler
war wie würdet ihr dieses bild schreibt
mal in die kommentare
ich schreibe ich doch meinen vorschlag
in die kommentare okay so das last jetzt
schön trocknen dann zeichne ich die
ballerina zähle wette drauf und die x
ich einfach ein bisschen blum klar damit
ich so ein schatten habe von der
ballerina silhouette und anschließend
kann ich seine bonbons aufkleben
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt die silhouette der
ballerina und ich werde jetzt künstlich
ein bisschen in die länge strecken das
heißt den oberkörper zeigt nicht
ziemlich weit oben fördern beim kleid
auf und machten die beiden ein bisschen
wie darunter damit einfach die pompons
hier reinpassen
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich das schön dunkel anlass
trocknen und dann kann ich beim nächsten
mal die pompons draufkleben
[Musik]
die ballerina ist jetzt getrocknet die
pom pom kette die wir jetzt hier gleich
drauf geklebt und damit sanierer die
lichterkette auf anmachen kann verstecke
ich denn alle aus schalter direkt hinter
dem wild und zwar so dass sie praktisch
seitlich mit dem finger und auch gut
dran glaubt und damit das bild dann
nicht schief hängt muss ich jetzt hinten
noch hölzer draufkleben einfach uns
auszugleichen
am besten auf alle vier seiten
denn an aus schalter und die holtzbrinck
lebe ich mit etwas heißkleber an und
nicht ganz am rand sondern ein bisschen
weiter versetzt nach innen so dass man
es nicht von der seite direkt sieht
[Musik]
juni pompons die lege ich mir jetzt erst
mal so hin wie ich sie auch aufgeklebt
haben möchte meine sinne jetzt mit
lichterkette alternativ hatte ich auch
diese pompons hier geholt
ihr könnt aber zb auch bonbons
selbermachen aus wolle oder einfach
teilnehmen und schön so gerafft und so
dreidimensionales bild draufkleben da
gibt es viele verschiedene möglichkeiten
ich fördere die hier abschätzen
[Musik]
ein selbst gemachtes sicht bild
kann er die schlechten träume einfangen
und gute träume in seinem ihres kopfes
dafür ist einfach
[Musik]
jetzt ist das kinderzimmer fertig sie
hatte hier schon ein paar monaten
gewohnt aber seit der umgestaltung
durfte sie nicht mehr ins zimmer das
heißt gesehen habt ihr es jetzt noch
nicht wenn ihr möchtet kann ich euch
übrigens auch noch im video machen und
zeigen wie ich sie mir als
kleiderschrank eingerichtet habe so dass
sie auch wirklich selber lernt ordnung
zu halten
jetzt ist sie gleich dass er hatte
gerade verletzt und ich hoffe dass ihr
das zimmer gefällt und ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat wenn ja
dann schreibt gerne in die kommentare
und schreibt mir gerne auch wenn das
video als nächstes sehen wollen bis zum
nächsten mal
soll ich die sanierung
[Musik]
hat sich positioniert ich jetzt hier 31
cholera ist geworden unser es hätte
vorgestellt und jetzt ist auch dein
bachelor das willst du nicht mehr raus
mein schatz
dann guckt das gästebett habe ich jetzt
da unten wo wir trotzdem freundin kommt
zum der schlacht kam es trotzdem
rausziehen genau und da oben können der
bisher kuschel oder so kommt ganze hier
an und ausschalten hier einfach ja fällt
aber nicht ab und kurz den schminktisch
habe ich verschönert rangeht geht fahren
wir auch die gold punkte und kommt jetzt
hier noch so nacht liegt mein deutscher
auch ein nachtlicht in der decke aber
wenn du zum beispiel noch lesen willst
dann kann es an lassen
ich glaube es geht sogar ganz gut und
dann kann es einfach ausmachen und jetzt
macht mir das spaß hier
jetzt kannst du deine bilder aufhängen
das ist dann kümmert da vielleicht noch
passieren machen
ok samira die ist schon alt genug die
macht dann schon eike der modifikation
ich glaube vielleicht kann man daraufhin
spannend und man kann sie da noch ich
selbst gemacht bin diesen noch draußen
nach dass hier jetzt hat auch
zum ihrer gemalt megacool muss man auch
gucken dass wir für sanierer in der
werkstatt schaffen für ihre
leinwandbilder kann deine freundin
warten schon
[Musik]